all right barack obama tonight being
forced to defend himself against
allegations that his south side chicago
presidential cent center will quote
gentrify the neighborhood raise prices
drive poor families from the area i
don't know maybe it's like obama disney
here's his response
the truth is anytime you do a big
project there's always going to be some
people who say well look we don't want
change we're worried about it we don't
know how it's going to turn out
which is why we've gone through such an
exhaustive process to encourage and
elicit
comments and and concerns and criticism
and suggestions from the community
here for reaction georgia senate
candidate hersha walker along with fox
news contributor leo 2.0 terrell you
know i i don't really understand it i'm
all for like i couldn't understand
ocasio-cortez the real speaker of the
house herschel walker when amazon wanted
to create these jobs in her district i'd
be like all over that
why didn't she allow that well i i want
to see
you know areas in chicago get investment
money this will this will be like disney
obama disney you get to see everything
obama
well you know sometimes sean you're
never going to make someone happy now
this is an opportunity that the obamas
have to empower that community so people
should be applauding it rather than
making fun of it or they should be
talking about something that's very
great there that you know mayor
lightfoot went from uh what defunding
the police to funding the police because
right now what the obama's talking about
is giving people jobs but i think you
got to hold people accountable and what
i mean by that is they got to hire
people from that neighborhood that work
at that library they got to hire people
in that neighborhood to build a library
and i think then they're doing a great
job
and you know and this is the thing leo i
mean we want money invested money
creates you know construction jobs it
creates full-time jobs you gotta you
know the obama library you got you know
people that that work and give tours and
concession stand people i don't know
what you have at a library i've been to
the reagan library nixon library i like
them uh but why wouldn't you want that
and think that's a good thing
it is a good thing but let me be as
clear as i can and explain to the
viewers this is the ultimate act of
selfishness on the part of the obama
sean that libraries would cost
550 million dollars he really want to
help the people of color people who look
like him built that library in the
poorest area of chicago the black area
for economic development does he do that
no no no he goes to the lake front he
takes the nicest part of the black area
and he wants to destroy that the
lakefront why won't he build it in the
inner city this is the this is the man
who's using his color to to basically
downplay the criticism environmentalists
and activists are saying don't build it
here build it in chicago in the south
side where people of color are hurting
he's not listening to them he's nothing
more than a land barrier honestly
i'm gonna tell you my big one of my
biggest criticisms you know all through
the obama years herschel walker this was
the only show we would scroll the names
of all the people that nobody hears
their names the people shot the people
shot and killed
nobody paid attention nobody cares uh is
george floyd important yes but every
single person shot and killed in chicago
every weekend they're important too and
i've been doing this since 2009
on this program and nobody ever lifts a
finger and every weekend another 50
people shot another 12 people dropped or
killed in a shooting
well you know one of the things sean and
i'm going to disagree with leo just a
little bit because i love leo he's my
brother but i i said you know even
though he was telling me
part of chicago wait a minute but but no
no no you you you're
you don't know sean but what i'm gonna
say here real quick is just that you
know i think you can empower this
community a little bit and at the same
time i think people got to worry about
law and order i think you got to empower
this community but you're also going to
have policing that's got to come into
that as well so now you're going to have
policing that's going to be paid more
money and that's what i was talking
about earlier has anyone ever talked
about what mayor lightfoot decided that
you know defunding the police didn't
work
that now i got to fund the police and i
said that's what we need to be talking
about not worried about something like
this right here the library that can
also help people
at the end of the day if you don't have
law and order and safety and security
you can't pursue happiness by the way
leo's supporting your candidacy and so
am i looking forward to you being called
senator herschel walker more hannity
next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else